gentlemen this is Hans Kim hey
[Applause]
it's great to be here at the comedy
Mothership the capital a stand-up comedy
right here on 6th Street
where you can see homeless people
playing music by scratching scabs on
their face
[Music]
and child prostitutes are yelling the
n-word at each other
feel sorry for those losers in L.A and
New York
too busy being like how will I know if
I'm successful if the NPC peacock isn't
molesting me
their holes are perfectly sized for
corporate [__]
in Texas
I'm an Asian in Texas I don't give a
[__] about the LGBT
the only LGBT I care about is the
Bluetooth on my LG TV
I'm having sex with this woman who has
an IUD and she stopped getting her
period
thank you
it's amazing it's like [__] a dude
I don't even have to worry about the
moon anymore it's like oh it's a waxing
gibbous I got three more days
all right that's my time thank you all
right
Hans Kim with a full minute stand-up
comedy how do you feel Hans I feel
amazing
um there's this is a two a week this is
uh kind of a lot for me but you know I'm
happy to be here and not in the alley
right of course you're talking about the
fact that we are doing a special taping
here there's another one tomorrow night
so you have to write two minutes this
week and we know that you have a new
girlfriend who's been distracting you a
lot from the actual art form of writing
and Performing you are not used to
having a white girl giving you [__] any
time that you want he brought her she
was in The Green Room this week and I I
don't like it
I don't
pretty attractive and I don't like it
I'm sorry Shane I was mad when I saw it
yeah here's a [__] Rolex and a hot
white girlfriend
I was here a month ago and it wasn't
going this well
it's starting to [__] bother me
it is true Hans made his way into the
Green Room one of these nights I
specifically remember because he was
wearing a weird Brown Indiana Jones
cowboy hat and I said how do you look
like both of the heroes from Indiana
Jones
and he was moving around he didn't sit
down and he kept taking his hands in and
out of his pockets and I said Hans what
the [__] are you on and you said two
bumps of cocaine
so let's talk about this yeah that did
actually help I liked you more
you wear that Rolex around town yeah oh
you're a Target bro anyway let's yeah
yeah so how often are you doing little
bumps of cocaine as often as my
girlfriend makes me
oh so you're getting it from her yeah
she's a bad influence oh boy now the
plot thickens this is interesting I
didn't know this about this girl has
this been like this the whole time yeah
she's really big into whippets oh my god
wow okay sounds like a keeper
how often is she doing these type of uh
illicit drugs every day every day she
does cocaine every day she's on ketamine
right now wow she's a [__] wolf of
Sixth Street
come on guys
let's go so how give us some examples of
how her drug use has affected your life
like uh give us something like you know
have you ever ended up in a shady
situation because of her uh what's it
been like a month or two you've been
with her yeah we just usually sit on our
couch and she does whippets and then
she's like uh
and then like I just try to like rub her
feet or something
but uh mostly she's been really uh
passing out a lot
uh
yeah how old is she
she's legal
oh my God what kind of answer is that
huh
what does that mean how old is she she's
24. oh okay all right whippets though I
mean that's like a high school thing
yeah yeah she's red band wants to know
what you're doing with all the unused
whipped cream part
what a waste am I right just using all
the gas none of the gas you know what
I'm saying
cracker
who said cracker yeah
hey you said that yeah to me yeah you're
calling me a cracker well that's what
you use to make whippets oh you know
that [__] because yeah you've also I
used to do it in high school scores
okay we got both of our jokes in that
was great at the same time it was like
twice the power of both jokes
okay Hans so let's talk about it are you
happy in this relationship I'm very
happy she's a very happy girl uh
sometimes I catch her singing
that's just going on inside her head
constantly holy [__] and why do you
think she likes [__] you
um I got a good jawline uh
I'm pretty skinny
um also I'm like fun to be around uh
sometimes
I try to make her be happy you know
sometimes I'm like sad but sometimes I'm
not so maybe she likes it when I'm not
sad
I honestly don't know yeah I use this
actually how you talk
[Laughter]
the character is just for real yeah he's
like this sometimes I'm sad sometimes
I'm not yeah
yeah
is this a Drake song
is the IUD thing real yeah she doesn't
get periods so how long has that been
for the whole time she's known me wow
it's amazing are you just dumping your
[__] loads and loads wow
incredible incredible you never pull out
at all I used to
but then I was like why right
now you like it yeah it's it feels
better it's like if your penis is just
coming without anything touching it it
just like it hurts
really are something else Hans you are a
giant 11 year old boy it is incredible
are you concerned at all about her doing
this much drugs though and and whippets
and have you talked to her about it at
all no I think she's doing a great job
uh
she's really having a lot of fun and
that's what it's all about what does she
do for work she's in Supply Chain
management did she does she contribute
to anything that you guys do did she
ever pick up the tab or anything yeah
she's independently wealthy really yeah
damn well wait she's supply chain yeah
where's she work Norfolk Southern
[Laughter]
come on guys Hans Kim remember that
remember what happened
Hans you got the show started again
congratulations you're the man thank you
so much Hans Kim everybody that was Hans
Kim that was Hans Kim and now my hand
goes into the bucket
the brand new process